ASHISH JHA: We've heard from David Bates about the basic framework
for thinking about safety, and quality.
Today I am very excited to have Dr. Madhukar Pai with me.
Madhukar is an epidemiologist, he's a physician.
He trained clinically in India, got his PhD from Berkeley,
and holds the candidate chair in translational epidemiology,
and global health.
And directs the global health program at McGill.
Lots of titles, but we're really going to talk about today is quality, and TV.
We're gonna take this kind of broad concept of quality,
and drill into one of the most pressing ongoing challenges in health
for people around the globe, and that's tuberculosis.
Madhukar, thank you so much for doing this.
I'm really excited that you're here.
MADHUKAR PAI: Real pleasure, thank you for having me.
- I'm gonna jump right in, and give everybody
a little background about tuberculosis.
Obviously TB's been with us forever.
We've read about it in books from thousands of years ago.
- Egyptian mummies.
- Egyptian mummies, that's right.
And yet here we are 21st century, and it's still with us.
Have we been making progress?
Give us a little state of play of TB.
Where are we with TB?
How much progress have we made?
What's going on with tuberculosis globally?
- Really important issue.
Whenever I speak about the progress in TB
I show a slide of my grandfather in India, my mother's father.
Even my mother has no memory of him because he died in his 20s of TB.
Now I'm talking about 80 years ago, and we
know that there was nothing much anybody could have offered him.
Born in the wrong era, died so we could live with that.
But to have 1.5 million people dying of TB today
is just nuts because it's a curable bacterial infection.
And to have that many people dying even today
basically suggests that something is seriously off in how tbs managed.
- Yeah.
- There is no rush now to lose someone because we have the antibiotics.
The antibiotics are bloody cheap.
There is really no reason to lose someone to TB today.
A few people with severe drug resistant TB that I understand,
but most people are not dying of drug resistant TB.
- That's what I was gonna say.
Is the problem primarily now that everybody
who's dying, everybody who's really sick just
has really highly drug resistant TB?
Is that a major problem?
- No, no, not at all.
Drug resistant TB is a problem no doubt, but it's
mostly localized in some parts of the world.
- Got it.
- And the majority of deaths are not happening in drug resistant cases.
Numerically the numbers are relatively smaller.
From one point to eight millions are not drug resistant.
Most of them are drug sensitive TB.
They have somehow been botched up.
They have either received care too late, or they not received care at all,
or they've been just mismanaged in the various sectors of health care.
The mortality is staggeringly high, and today
actually, the WHO says TB has surpassed the death burden of HIV and malaria.
In other words, TB kills more people today than HIV and malaria combined.
- Wow.
- Which is the most recent statistics.
And it ranks in the top 10 causes of deaths in the global burden of disease
even today, in the 2015 data.
- Let me take a quick step back, and just unpack that a little bit.
One question that I was going to ask you is, how does TB
compare to these other big killers?
Malaria, HIV aids, sounds like we've made real progress
with HIV aids, and malaria.
Are we making progress?
Is TB getting better, but maybe just not getting better as fast?
Where it that at?
- The latest projections shows that in the last 15 years
TB deaths have declined by about 20%.
That's not bad.
- Yeah.
- But you still are left with a residual 1.8 million deaths a year.
Which means that for significant worse to start with.
- Yeah.
- Secondly, the numeric numbers of TB new cases have gone up.
The year before it was nine plus million.
The last world TB report, 2016, WHO increased it to 10.4.
- Wow.
- That's today's number.
10.4 million cases, and 1.8 million deaths.
- Wow, every year?
- Every year.
Every year new cases of TB every year, and almost half
a million drug resistant cases a year is the current estimates.
- Got it.
- In some ways numerically it's worsened compared to previous years.
Which is the opposite of what most infectious diseases are trending to,
and part of it is the fact that the numbers went up because of India.
It's not that India has suddenly discovered TB.
The private sector in India is starting to notify which as you know
is a whole another issue with TB.
When the private sector does not even tell you what they're are managing you
end up with this hole in the data set.
The honest answer is nobody in the world truly knows the true magnitude of TB.
Especially in countries like India.
There's a whole slew of non docs providers who are managing TB.
Who may not be telling anyone that they're managing TB.
When they start notifying the numbers jump up.
That's what happened in India.
- Got it.
10.5 million is almost surely an underestimate.
- Almost surely an estimate.
- And the numbers have gone up not because TB is number of TB cases
is exploding, but we're actually starting
to identify, and capture cases that have been there before,
but we just didn't know about it.
- We didn't know about it.
That's even true for drug resistance.
All of these decades we we're underestimating drug resistance
because we never even tested for it.
We we're using sputum smears which cannot detect drug resistance.
That was the dominant diagnostic tool for TB.
Now that we are starting to use molecular test like gene export,
suddenly we are seeing much more [INAUDIBLE] percent in MDR resistance.
Which again, I think is not because something suddenly
has exploded because we are more aware, we are looking for it now.
- Got it.
Both the burden, and the loss of life is not primarily
due to the underlying disease itself.
The underlying disease of course is problematic,
but we know how to manage it.
- We know how to manage it.
- And the second is that it's not that we have no strategy for coverage.
It's not that we have no ability to get people into care.
That doesn't strike me as the dominant problem.
And what I'm hearing is that the dominant problem really
is in the execution of what we do, and how comprehensively,
and effectively we do it.
Which is essentially another way of saying the primary problem.
At least one of the dominant problems, we don't have to rank it is quality.
- Yes.